all right hello everyone we are now
sitting down to John cumbers the founder
of Sinn bio beta which is the world's
largest synthetic biology conference
it's true yes and it thank you for
coming thank you for having me yes John
and I'd go back a little bit longer
which is nice it's not somebody that
we're meeting just today so that's nice
but so tell us about I mean we have
indie bio happening right now the
world's largest seed stage accelerator
we have some bio beta which happens
every single year we have AI
machine-learning blockchain technology
that's coming into this industry as well
what the hell's going on with the code
of life and where is it going teach us
about this well what's going on with it
I think we still I mean we're seeing
evolution in in action we're seeing the
tools of creation being democratized a
number of companies here the demo day
talked about CRISPR and gene editing
that's one of these amazing tools of
creation that the genetic engineer has
been dreaming off for a long time being
able to actually edit genes and cells in
vivo that is without killing them so
there's just a huge amount going on
right now that's where it's happening
right now where it's going in the future
you know I must space-cadet so I mean
we're engineering materials were
engineering our living cells to be
medicines for engineering food and
flavors so it's going into space its
genetic engineering synthetic biology is
the critical tool that we're gonna need
for space settlement so that's why it's
going in the future yes and so as we get
to the leveraging biology for space
settlement and all that good stuff what
are we doing in this short term because
there's some food companies here there's
pharma companies that come to you
there's so many people you guys
yeah awesome events so what are we doing
in these like kind of short-term steps
that are just blowing our mind you
listed CRISPR in genetic engineering
which is gonna let us get all the good
space colonization going as well but
what are you really seeing right now
that it's just blowing everything away I
think the the whole premise of synthetic
biology the whole definition of
synthetic biology is that we're making
biology easier to engineer
we've been engineering biology for the
last 3040 years with genetics we've been
engineering biology for the last 3,000
years using domestication and crop
breeding so I think the biggest impact
that we're seeing is on sustainable
feedstocks
and the ability to turn sustainable
feedstocks like co2 or glucose into
high-value materials and chemicals what
we've seen in the past is unsustainable
feedstocks and an unsustainable
feedstock in the case it's not obvious
is something like coal or oil which you
dig up or suck up from the ground and
you burn it and that co2 that's produced
has to go somewhere and it's been going
into our environment for the last 50
years what we're seeing with biology is
this ability to suck out the co2
directly from the air fix it into a
biological product and then when that
product is disposed of whether it's
waste food or waste material or any
other thing that you've made with
biology it just goes back into the air
so it's this closed-loop living system
where the co2 goes from the air into the
product back to the air and that's so
much better for the environment and it's
better for the bottom line of your of
your balance sheet as well because
you're not having to put in all these
resources into sucking up but
unsustainable resource and putting it
into the air and that's a crucial
example as humans are starting to
consume more energy on the planet and
we need to figure out how to write there
in the actual process of making whatever
we're making to make sure that we are
not emitting additional carbon emissions
in whatever ways possible okay and then
give us some other maybe of your
favorite examples of impact like freakin
Memphis meat is crazy over all the clean
meat companies clean dairy clean a clean
all the stuff and clean leather and then
we have all the ways that people are
manufacturing proprietary molecules to
help with any type of disease that's
occurring in the body or understanding
the microbiome there's so many of these
companies that are that are out here
just doing incredible things and like
you said we're just now really starting
to unpack this biotech explosion sure I
think some of the food brands that we're
seeing are very exciting some of the
consumer brands that we're very that
we're seeing a very exciting we saw one
today which was a company that was
making engineered wood yes that's really
cool and the fact that these are mostly
young entrepreneurs who are trying to
create a product trying to create a
brand and then take it directly to
market these are not to be plays these
are b2c plays and I think that's really
exciting
yes I've loved being a part of indie bio
ecosystem because I've had the
opportunity to help science has become
entrepreneurs that's such a fun process
yeah because there's such brilliant
people in the world and then it's like
the the barriers for them are maybe
learning how to speak about their
product in a concise way or learning how
to market it really well or learning how
to build rapport with people or there's
so many like so many processes that may
be but they can go crazy talking about
how much they love their product and how
the nuance of that they can get really
deep in so you seem to be on both ends
you're very scientific but you're also
very business C so that's really
important to know how to do that
yeah and scientists hate marketing
I mean we're not programmed to market
things at all so you have to end it and
even if you did like marketing it will
be beaten out of you in grad school so
yeah you've got a you've and that's
because marketing is not about data and
facts marketing is about perception and
feelings and it's more psychology than
psycho psychologically driven than data
driven yeah that can be both yeah yeah
do you what is you have a retreat that's
coming up we do yeah yeah tell us a
little bit about the retreat
I'm not sure whether I want to tell
about the retreat fair enough
in by only thing okay then yeah then
that's good Winston bio beta sin by beta
is October 1 through 3 here in San
Francisco at the Mission Bay conference
center we've got some amazing speakers
lined up some amazing sessions over a
thousand people are gonna be there yes
but the bigger thing and the thing that
we're launching that's new for 2018 is
called synthetic biology week rule and
that's happening from the end of
September through October 6th and there
are over a hundred satellite events that
are gonna be occurring throughout the
Bay Area whoa
synthetic biology week exactly and so
everybody coordinates through you to
host their event yeah well just drop us
an email and we'll put him on the
schedule each sessions 90 minutes and go
exonerol nine zero and we've got a whole
range of different activities going on
from an art show that you know Ryan is
putting on of her ah ah she's she is
amazing
Kinkaid riling a Bonneville Labs is
throwing an after-party at one of the
labs at the end of the day there's some
activities going on at D CVC data
collective the venture fund that I'm
involved with a huge amount of fun and
activities and it's really designed to
get the technology out of the conference
and out of the lab and into people's
hands so that's what all of these
satellite events are designed to do hell
yes and so then what is the info @
symbol beta comm for email for - yeah I
think that would work yeah yeah info at
yeah why don't we do that one again yeah
info at sin by obey the doc yeah you can
email us info at sin better combo you
can go to the website sign up with the
newsletter we send a newsletter out
every week of your who's being funded
what they're doing new product launches
your events like this we put this will
be put into every Indian device demo day
in the newsletter tomorrow boom yeah
awesome anything else oh do you think's
important sure let me tell you one thing
that I've been working on I probably put
out as a blog post so one thing that
we've been doing lately is working with
Minerva University Gerda and a student
group of 5 students and we've been doing
a survey on genetic literacy and we've
found some interesting results the goal
of the project medical literacy genetic
literacy is is how much you understand
about biology ok and in particular the
question that we had the hypothesis we
had was that anti-gmo sentiments will be
correlated with a low genetic literacy
yep then the more people understood
about biology and genetics the less
anti-gmo they would be yeah
would you agree that you would think
that there's a coral
between those two things who do you
think so so what's interesting was that
we found zero correlation between
people's general interest and their
perception did you Emma how many two
hundred two hundred people yeah the one
thing that was holding me back from
potentially saying that was that I
thought that a lot of people that do
study GMOs and become anti GMOs
understands a little bit about biology
because sometimes you don't just riot
because of riding but you're riding
because you read and learn and then
you're like I don't think so and then
yeah yeah I haven't met and I love to
meet some people who do have a deep
understanding of biology and
irrationally Andy yeah I would not say
I'm rationally anti GMO I would say I
just proposed anti GMO questions
because of just being a
thought-provoking person hmm and I don't
have a deep understanding of biology I
have a very surface level 10,000 foot
view of it and I I just think we need
more longitudinal tests we've talked
about this before so we'll just we'll
see exactly what that ends up being like
after you eat a genetically modified
tomato for forty years and then you have
to try and analyze the million markers
that are in your body to see what
happens so good luck being able to do
that and you remember my my
counter-argument to the longitudinal
tests what was it again the counter
argument was that if you're worried
about random genetic changes that are
occurring or you're worried about
genetic changes that are occurring then
you shouldn't be eating anything that's
crossed with anything because there's
many more random genetic changes that
occur through natural breeding than
there are through genetic engineering
yes but then there is also the drought
resistant and the insect resistant in
the pesticide or is this an all baked
into one item and then you're eating
that one item those are not
that's so that's already stacking up
quite a bit and we don't know what that
looks like eating that for for two years
but you bring up a good point and I'd
have to know the the exact details of
the of each trait that you're and what
it is that it's how it's changing the
plan and how that might affect what
happens in nature in our body yeah but
if you really want to to to eat you know
natural unmodified foods then then you'd
really have to go back 3,000 years and
worry about you know trying to eat a
diet of domesticated crops if that's
what you're worried about
well or potentially the future of
organic farming being the only style of
farming because we don't need we figured
out how to build ecosystems of only
organic farming and I think that that's
very possible and I would hope for that
rather than putting food farms in
deserts or in places that have large
amounts of insects or the need
pesticides that have drought etc so and
do you do you do you think that
pesticides are a bad thing I think that
they feed the pesticides enable people
to be fed right now which is really
important you're you you eating Dismore
important than you potentially being
slightly hurt from a pesticide down a
couple are you um are you happy with
eating organic pesticides I have not
studied enough to know what an organic
pesticide would it would it would even
that is and because there's a lot of
pesticides that I used on organic food
yeah some of them which are a lot worse
than synthetic pesticides that he used
on non-organic food what about an
ecosystem of food that doesn't need even
organic pesticides so as in as an as in
a either a closed farm ecosystem where
you're eating the perfect amount of
nutrients from the soil from the star
from the rain from water from everything
and then you're not needing to do any
drought resistant food genetic
engineering or backdoor insecticide or
pesticide etc hmm have you ever drunk a
pesticide before no have you a lot you
drink it yeah
because you want to test it on your body
no just cause I don't want bacteria in
the water that I'm drinking so we put
chlorine in it to kill her
where were you well in my kitchen me
pesticides a pretty useful things for
killing unwanted bacteria if we didn't
put them in a water like chlorine then
when you turn on then you'd have to boil
every single cup of water that you that
you drank with all that you brushed your
teeth with which they do in countries
like Bangladesh but they don't have
chlorinated water systems and
infrastructure to kill the water they
boil every cup yeah well the water that
comes out of the San Francisco in New
York and other cities water systems is
able to be drink because it has a small
tiny parts per million of chloride yeah
so the results of the study showed that
that there was no correlation if there's
200 people but the second interesting
result was the was that there was no
aunty GMO perception either yeah I
shouldn't say there wasn't and and there
was oh I guess I can say there was an ID
GMO we would think that if you surveyed
people in the Bay Area that the majority
of people would be anti GMO I would
applaud that in the Bay Area anywhere I
mean in the u.s. in the Bay Area the
feeling is that there's an anti GMO
movement that is rife and the data
actually said that didn't exist there
was neutral perception 50 50 50 no I
mean it wasn't out of the 200 wasn't yes
it's a small survey but it wasn't
statistically significant so why do you
think we have this anti GMO perception
why do we think that people are anti
general
foods something that we eat three times
a day food something that's very close
to our hearts and it's something that's
difficult to be educated about biology
to its full extent that is true
now there's another theory there's
something Crowe Kroger oh yeah the
dunning-kruger
dunning-kruger and I think that has a
lot to do it it's a confirmation bias
dunning-kruger effect it basically says
that the more that you know about
something the more that you
underestimate your ability to do it the
less you know about something the more
you overestimate your ability to make a
statement about it and so in this case
yes a lot of people and in basically
every case about everything
the more that you meditate and the more
that you lose your ego to psychedelics
and that you have a very open mind and
all these different types of practices
that you can do the more you're just
willing to just be like you know I don't
know the more you're willing to be
open-minded to talk to somebody it's
conservative-liberal more you're willing
to talk somebody that's anti GMO that's
pro GMO and that kind of stuff and then
that way you learn and it's another
things investing your time invested time
of each day into learning when you come
home
don't just watch cat videos for six
hours watch you know watch documentary
like food evolution for a little while
and watch and try and learn be skeptical
to everything but just try and learn and
everything so it goes deep but I do
think that that has essence in every
conversation basically but try our best
to not be egotistical about what we know
or what we don't know but just be
open-minded about things in general but
what why is this so important to you
it's not it's a side project I was doing
it on Saturday morning with these
students but what I wanted to do was to
start on an education in issue
to educate people about genetics I think
it's cool I think I think so I think yes
and and I also want don't I don't want
there to be an anti GMO movement or
perception because I think the
technology can do a lot of good in the
world and I think it's damaging the
environment and it's yeah it's it's I
think there's a lot of awesomeness that
can happen through through amazing GMOs
the same thing can be said about genetic
engineering there could be a whole
genetic engineering block that movement
of people that are like no regulate
crazy and I think that there's a little
bit of truth in that just like there
might be a little bit of truth in the
anti GMO potentially